الينا الان من الخرطوم اسامه عثمان ابو
بكر مدير اداره التواصل في الهلال الاحمر
السوداني سيد اسامه حدثنا عن الجانب
الانساني الذي افرزته هذه المواجهه ان كان
في الخرطوم او في المدن التي تعيش هذه
الاشتباكات
في عندنا وجود في سبعه محافظات اللي ممكن
نسميها نحن نسميها سبعه محافظات في
الولايه الخرطوم الكبرى اللي هي تشهد
اعمال العنف الموجوده
محتاج تدخلات عائله الابيض
يعني الوضع الصحي الوضع قاتم شويه ونحن
بالناشد للكل معظم المنظمات والجهات
المعينه انه
بالذات للمستشفيات وللطوارئ في المستشفيات
لانه المستشفيات فوق القدرات الطبيعيه
بتاعته الاحتياجات الفعليه
ابرز الاحتياجات الاكثر الحاحا الان سيد
اسامه
الاحتياجات اللي هي
المعالجات في الطوارئ يعني يعني نحن
بنتكلم عن على حاجات متقدمه اللي هي عمليه
جراحيه وكده لكن هي العمليات الطوارئ اللي
هي المساعده
بالاسعافات الموجوده
والرعايه الاوليه والوسيطه للمصاعدين يعني
واحد اثنين
الكوادر في المستشفيات الموجوده في الوقت
المحتاجها مساعدات محتاجه الان
ماشي ان احنا موضوع الاطراف
المتحايبه حاليا انه تسمح
السوداني والفرق كلها اللي هي بتحمل شعار
الهلال الاحمر السوداني او اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر بسهوله الحركه لانه دي
بتقيد بالقانون وهي فرق محايده من مساعدات
الضحيه
عمل هذه الفرق
سيد اسامه
من كل الاطراف وكل الاطراف عارفه انه
الفرق بتحديدا الهلال الاحمر السوداني هي
في محايده
ونعم تشتغل بموجب القانونيه ماذا عن
الاصابات التي وقفتهم عليها
والتي نتجت عن هذه المواجهه ما درجتها ما
طبيعتها وما مدى خطورتها ايضا
هي
هي يعني المتوسطه تقريبا هي متوسطه وهي
معظمها في معظمها الاصابات موجوده
عن المعارك يعني احيانا
اي طرف بانه ممكن يتعمد بطبيعه الحال يعني
المرتبطه بالمزاع الموجود انه تحاول
يعني
على حياه المدنيين الموجودين اللي بيكونوا
موجودين في المناطق الفحص كان معارك وانك
تبعد عن المناطق اللي فيها مدنيين
ونحن برضه بنناشد للمره الثانيه والثالثه
ورابعه انه الاسواق المتحاربه تلتزم
بالتزام
القانون الدولي الانساني او اتفاقيات جنيه
انه
تحافظ على حياه الناس
المحمولين بالحمايه يعني
طريقتكم الان السيد اسامه في التعامل مع
هذا النقص على مستوى الهياكل الطبيه
والكوادر الطبيه
والله نحن طبعا عندنا كوادر المدربه في
الاخلاء
من يعني الاخلاء للمستشفيات اقرب مستشفيات
برعايه الصحيه الاوليه والاسعافات الاوليه
فنحن بنستغفر دائما للمتطوعين في مختلف
الاماكن على اساس انه يسد النقص يلا نحن
التعامل في الحالات الطبيه بمعنى قلت
الاخلاء وعمل مستشفيات بالكوادر بتاعتنا
اللي هي بتساعد الاطباء في مهامهم هم
الكواكب في عندنا الجزء الاول الاساس
الاستقبال اللي هي الاسعافات الاوليه
والرعايه الصحيه الاوليه فنحن عندنا وجود
مقدم حاليا او كل المواد احنا بنحاول نعمل
جديد في المستشفيات كلها في المناطق بتاعت
الخرطوم اللي هي الولايه
التي تستمر في الوصول الى المستشفيات او
ايضا ضحايا هذه المواجهه
لا ليست لدينا حاليا احصائيه دقيقه ممكن
نحن نعلن عنها
وفي هذه الاثناء العدد يعني
ايضا نقابه اطباء السودان تناشد الكوادر
الطبيه التوجه لمستشفى بشائر ومستشفى شرق
النيل بالخرطوم هل هناك مستشفيات
متضرره اكثر من غيرها او تستقطب وتستقبل
اكثر من غيرها اصابات وتفتقر ربما
للوسائل والادوات لمواجهه هذه الاعداد
الكبيره من الجرحى
نعم هي كل كل المستشفيات الموجوده حاليا
نحن نتعامل مع شاب مستشفيات في كل محليه
في مستشفى معين كلها محتاجه دعم كل
المستشفيات محتاجه لدعم لانه الطاقه
الحاليه الاستيعابيه الحاليه ما مصممه
للاستيعاب المصابين بالوقت وبالتالي هم
كلهم محتاجين دعم لانهم بيعانوا النقص اول
حاجه في الادويه المنتظره للحياه في
الكوادر الطبيه محتاجين نقصي حتى في
البيئه بتاعه المحتاجين دعم في البيئه حتى
بتاعه العمل
الاسيره مع كافيه
وطبعا الاستقرار الطاقه الكهربائيه برضو
مطلوبه في
محتاجين دعم كامل لانه
نعم اسامه ابو بكر عثمان مديره اداره
التواصل في الهلال الاحمر السوداني كنت
معنا من الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك